A rolling stone gathers no moss.
But a walking, talking pile of them?
That's another story.
Marvel fans noticed a slight change to Korg
between his appearances in Thor: Ragnarok
and Avengers: Endgame, which illustrates the
extent to which he, Miek, and Thor let themselves
go during Endgame's five-year time jump.
When Bruce Banner and Rocket arrive in New
Asgard to attempt to recruit the Thunder God
for the Avengers' time heist, Korg's lovely
blue hue is also marked by patches of green.
Yes, the affable rock dude is suffering from
a bit of a moss infestation.
"Long time, no see."
"Beer's in the bucket!
Feel free to log on to the Wi-fi!"
If you pause the movie to examine him closely,
which you can now that Avengers: Endgame is
available digitally, you can see that he's
downright lousy with the stuff.
Astute Reddit user AmazingSpdrman1 was the
first to point out the change, writing:
"In Endgame, you can see Korg has moss forming
on his rocks that was not there in Ragnorok,
showing how gross the lives of the 'boys'
have become."
Though some eagle-eyed viewers noticed during
the movie's theatrical run, it's easy to miss
this subtle visual signifier during the scene,
considering it's the introduction of the version
of Thor the directors called "Bro Thor."
Thor's extra pounds the result of five years
of terrible eating habits, even worse drinking
habits, and sitting around playing Fortnite
have been the subject of all manner of commentary
since Endgame's release.
While some fans lamented the fact that the
Asgardian's weight gain, fueled by depression
over his failure to stop Thanos from decimating
half of all life in the universe, was played
for cheap jokes, others were positively moved
by the filmmakers' sensitive treatment of
what seemed to be PTSD.
Helped along by Chris Hemsworth's performance,
Endgame accomplished what no previous Marvel
film had done: it brought the God of Thunder
down to Earth, showing us mere mortals that
not even he is immune from depression and
its effects.
"No.
Yes.
I think I'm losing it."
There was a heck of a lot going on in Endgame's
entire 3-plus hour run time, so fans could
be forgiven for overlooking a few patches
of creeping foliage.
But, now that we've pointed it out, you won't
be able to unsee it.
It's an understated way to suggest that Thor
isn't the only one who has been sitting on
his butt for five years.
Thankfully, we'll almost certainly get to
see more of Korg, and perhaps he will have
cleaned himself up a bit.
Thor: Ragnarok director Taika Waititi, who
voices the lovable stack of stones, has officially
signed on to helm Thor: Love and Thunder,
which will make Odinson the first Avenger
to get a fourth solo outing.
The movie, scheduled to hit screens November
5, 2021, will see the return of Natalie Portman
as Jane Foster, who will follow the character's
comics arc by taking up Mjolnir to become
the Mighty Thor.
Where that iteration of Mjolnir will come
from, since Captain America returned the one
from 2013 back to its time, is a question
yet to be answered.
We can only imagine Korg's reaction to this
development.
Will he think that the Odinson has somehow
become a woman?
"Sounds like you had a pretty special and
intimate relationship with this hammer and
that losing it was almost comparable to losing
a loved one."
At any rate, Korg's little hygiene problem
in Endgame illustrates the fact that this
massive film is probably still hiding scores
of small but significant details, and it wouldn't
surprise us if more than a few of them are
still yet to be noticed by fandom at large.
Of course, scouring the flick for every last
hidden treasure just got a lot easier with
its digital release, and if physical media
is more your speed, it'll be out on Blu Ray
and DVD August 13.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.